[Music]
august 2021 saw the first trailer for no
way home hit the internet and suffice to
say fans absolutely lost their minds
they were met with returning villains
head-scratching revelations and more but
it wasn't enough it didn't take long for
the marvel fandom to call for a second
teaser and at long last marvel studios
and sony pictures have obliged aside
from giving us a better sense of what to
expect from the film our latest look at
no way home is packed with small details
that you might have missed the no way
home trailer was full of interesting
parallels that served as callbacks to
former spidey flicks perhaps the biggest
reference to an older film came toward
the end of the trailer when mj falls off
some scaffolding and it looks like peter
may or may not be able to save her in
time we see their hands almost come
together but we'll have to wait for the
movie to see if mj is saved fans of the
amazing spider-man 2 were likely taken
back to the tragic moment when gwen
stacy dies in the film after falling
from a clock tower peter tries his best
to save her but even though his web
latches onto her at the last second it
doesn't do so in time to prevent her
from hitting the ground
the camera work in no way home shows mj
falling the exact same way zooming in on
her face with wide eyes as she plummets
in slow motion let's just hope mj's fall
has a much better outcome r.i.p gwen
it's worth noting that the first mj
actress kirsten dunst also had a
dramatic falling scene in 2002's
spider-man though thankfully she
survived it fingers crossed that the
same holds true this time around as
virtually all of the spider-man no way
home marketing material has revealed tom
hall and spidey will do battle with
villains from across multiple spider-man
film franchises yes even the widely
panned amazing spider-man series is
getting in on the action with reese
evans lizard and jamie foxx's electro
returning for another go around the
former dr kirk connors looks largely the
same as he did in 2012's the amazing
spider-man but that sentiment doesn't
apply to his electrifying companion
who's sporting an entirely new look when
the amazing spider-man 2 hit theaters in
2014 fans weren't very keen on electro's
updated appearance the glowing blue skin
and black bodysuit didn't remind fans of
the fabled spiderman foe in the least
echoing the visuals of the ultimate
spider-man comics version more than the
classic incarnation that everyone loved
thankfully it seems that no way holmes
corrected this creative misstep by
giving max dillon a more steep ditko
inspired aesthetic the second trailer
showed off the new and improved electro
and all of his lightning bolt masked
glory ditching the neon blue altogether
of course this begs a question is this
version of the character even the same
as the one from the amazing spider-man
sequel or if we look to the disney plus
series loki for multiverse clues is it a
variant electro we'll just have to wait
and see
one of the big focuses of the new
spider-man no way home trailer is how
all of these villains are supposed to
die fighting spider-man
they all die fighting spider-man
it's their fate
i'm sorry kid and with tom holland
spidey being the good guy that he is it
seems or at least the trailer implies
that he wants to save them in some way
even as he battles them perhaps this
points to the antagonists of no way home
not being the old villains what if
there's a bigger foe behind all of this
after all alfred molina's doc ock seems
oddly mentor-like to peter in the
trailer which fits with his sympathetic
interpretation in spider-man 2 as well
of course it's important to note that
trailers for mcu films are notoriously
filled with misdirection so who knows if
any of what's shown here is what
actually happens in the film another
factor to consider here is the role of
doctor strange in the film while he
seemed to genuinely want to help peter
fix the mess that they've made together
he also seems to be at odds with peter's
apparent mission to save the villains
from their fate will the big conflict
brew between the two is dr strange more
of an antagonist than a supporting
character here again misdirection is a
big tool in the mcu trailer playbook but
it would be an interesting direction for
the film to take nonetheless of all the
shocking and exciting new reveals and
the newest spider-man no way home
trailer we arguably get the most from
otto octavius
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
however while doc himself is wonderfully
familiar there's something different
about his famous tentacles this change
appears during two scenes with tom
holland's spider-man in the trailer when
you look closely the tentacles seem to
have a coating of red that was not
present in spider-man 2 a color that
could indicate stark technology the
reason for this would be unclear but
probably has something to do with doc
ock's arrival in the mcu for instance
did he steal stark tech from peter's
spider-man costume and rework it to fit
his tentacles if anyone could one-up
tony stark it would be the brilliant
octavius did he break into a stark
facility and sneak a peek himself either
way an upgraded dock is not something
spidey should be happy to see
in the first trailer for no way home
there were subtle hints at the villains
we would see in the film the only sure
thing was the appearance of doc ock who
showed up swinging his metal tentacles
like the good old days sandman electro
green goblin and lizard were hinted at
but we never saw them outright that all
changed in the second trailer here we
have been given head-on views for all
four baddies and we even hear some
dialogue from electro and green goblin
you're not gonna take this away from me
peter
you're struggling this surely confirms
that peter will be taken on a group of
super villains long rumored to be the
sinister six but if so who is the sixth
villain for that matter will there be a
sixth villain the comic book super
villain team surely isn't called the
sinister five but if there is a sixth
bad guy in the mix then sony and marvel
studios have done a fabulous job of
keeping this mystery character just that
the biggest fan speculations online
suggest the sixth member is vulture
mysterio or venom all have solid chances
of showing up in the film and maybe
we'll get more than six villains after
all
one of the most incredible shots from
the no way home trailer comes toward the
end when peter is flying in the air
toward electro sandman and lizard while
we never rule our spidey outs it's an
unfair fight and it doesn't look like
peter stands a chance luckily it seems
like this is not a three on one battle
based on the position of the characters
in the scene where they are facing and
where they appear to be heading it
definitely looks like this is a three on
three battle the only villain that seems
to be going for peter is sandman who is
staring him straight on lizard's
positioning makes it look more like he's
going to breeze right past peter and
electro seems to be facing upward away
from the webb slinger this very well
could be the scene when peter and two
other spider-men that would be toby
mcguire and andrew garfield that the
past year of rumors is correct team up
and attack the super villains together
marvel trailers are known for editing
out characters and objects and it's
highly probable they were removed from
this pivotal scene in order to save the
appearance for the final film
the mcu spider-man is no stranger to
overcoming insurmountable odds and
villains of all shapes and sizes he has
already put adrian toombs better known
as the vulture behind bars and thwarted
quentin mysterio facts evil schemes in
addition to bravely squaring off with
thanos multiple times however it's clear
that he's biting off a little more than
he could chew and no way home by
standing up to multiple super powered
rogues at once to make matters worse the
loudmouth j jonah jameson will be there
to watch it all go down after making the
daily bugle's editor-in-chief a
highlight in director sam raimi's
spider-man trilogy jk simmons returned
as a new version of j jonah jameson via
far from home instead of barking orders
at his newspaper staff he is now a desk
pounding talk show host with a clear
dislike for spider-man his 2019 comeback
was a huge surprise to moviegoers
leading them to wonder if it was a mere
one-off or simmons was in for the long
haul the second no way home trailer
supplied the answer by showing fans a
quick glimpse of the mcu scaling
mustachio jameson on a city street time
will tell how much screen time he'll
score this time around
back when the first trailer for
spider-man no way home came out we got a
sense of how all the chaos in the film
comes to be peter asks dr strange to
perform a spell that will make everyone
forget who is behind spider-man's mask
while the spell is being conjured peter
panicked that aunt may ned and mj won't
remember who he is so mj's gonna forget
about everything we've ever been through
stop tampering with the spell oh my god
ned he's my best friend oh my aunt may
should believe talking
the no way home trailer seems to confirm
that the spell doesn't go quite as
planned or does it mj and ned are
peppered throughout the trailer and they
all seem to know peter as spider-man at
various points in time granted no
trailer is ever put together in
chronological order so this can't be
definite but it does look like doctor
strange could not complete his spell or
that if he did so the loved ones who
peter did name were somehow spared from
the great memory loss either way given
the fact that there's now a bunch of
multiverse madness going on it appears
as if peter's non-stop chattering during
the conjuring really did blow things
wide open and it probably would have
been best to keep his mouth shut
assuming again that this isn't marvel
once again using the trailers to
misdirect us
spider-man no way home hits theaters on
december 17th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite marvel movies are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one